I wanted to talk about motorcycles do
and the hog hunt
um so in my book in chapter 12 there's a
section
titled on a motorcycle now we didn't
have GoPros when I rode bikes bikes were
my thing it was my jam for quite a few
years uh Still Loving the bits but I've
switched over to supercars as I stated
in my book
so this is a uh
I'm guessing by this angle
uh here I'm gonna go Fuller screen so
you guys can see this more because it's
sort of pulled back
um let's go to this angle here
and let me just make sure the audio is
playing
sorry
uh
do yeah okay so this is a GoPro mounted
with audio by the look of the angle this
would be the windshield and the mirror
of the bike and the gas tank I see Ninja
over here so this is definitely the
windshield so a lot of times when guys
are on a motorcycle they'll now Mount
GoPros on their windshield facing them
or on their helmet facing the road kind
of like a dash cam and also as an
opportunity to just sort of you know
record stuff I can see this guy's bike
here is still running because his
headlights on or maybe he just switched
it off in the in the ACC settings still
on uh and this one here the guy's
camera's still on but it looks like they
just got off the bikes and here's what's
about to happen
you will
now
if you guys can't hear it or you can't
see the captions this young girl walks
up to this guy over here and says I have
a question could you take me for a ride
on your bike uh she looks attractive to
me and his response is he will
I don't know that's that's pretty soft
but the point of this is
the reason why I said in that chapter on
a bike is because it's it's basically
cheat code for young men for everything
for transportation for speed for Thrills
um and for women too like this would I'm
not going to say this would routinely
happen but it but it happens more than
you think that because you're riding a
motorcycle and they're exciting tools
and they're not boring and as I always
say you can do anything to a woman
except for them motorcycles are
definitely not boring and it forces
intimacy
um between you and the passenger because
she's leaning on you she's got her arms
around your waist you're probably
scaring the living crap out of her uh
being on the back of a motorcycle on a
sport bike is terrifying I did not
realize how terrifying it is to be on
the back of a bike until I had to hop on
the back of a friend's bike to get a
ride somewhere to get mine because I
left it
um long story short it was maybe like a
six or seven minute ride and I've been
riding probably for about seven years at
that time I think I was on the back of a
Gixxer 750 and uh it's you're wide open
you're up high the sensation of speed is
tremendous
um it's it's just wild so I mean I don't
like I will never go in the back of a
bike again screw that just just give me
an Uber now we didn't have the choice of
Ubers back then and probably because I
was poor in my 20s too so I didn't have
that option either but you get the idea
like they are cheat codes so just check
this out
probably
I want you so bad they're so cool yeah
he'll probably give you a ride
would you give everyone I have so both
of these girls now want a ride on the
motorcycle just random girls walking up
to dudes give us a ride on your
motorcycle I have a new tire on it so
he's given the lamest excuse I have a
brand new tire on the back so it's kind
of slick
it's not really how it works but sure if
you're scared sure you're good but he'll
probably give you a ride I'm okay
right the cute girls are young they're
pretty
I fell off and it hurts
I'll drive it actually I'm like yeah I
know because I just saw new tires
they're like really slippery what kind
of bike is it
hard
these girls are like begging like do
something interesting with us take us
for a ride buy us a coffee talk to us
entertain us somehow anything other than
just leave us alone right here right now
women don't generally walk up to guys
like this so so they're different yeah
these chicks by the way are not
interested whatsoever
in the make or model or how much power
or how wide the tire is or any of the
stuff that he's starting to talk about
they just want to hang around the bikes
and be on them for a ride
I don't know it depends on what mood
he's in we're almost we're on the
highway and some guy was like swerving
around in this Lane
and he got pulled over he's probably
driving so we stopped
we drove past him and he like swerved at
us so
anyway
so
get a bike if you haven't read my book
talk about why I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out